hagamos algunos ejercicios de la
introducción a la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen esta vez tenemos este
problema nos dicen cuál es la pendiente
de la recta dada por la siguiente
ecuación y observa esto está en la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen así que
solo para recordar la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen es de la forma game
es igual a mx
+ b y es igual a mx más b en donde m es
el coeficiente del término x que es
nuestra pendiente déjame anotarlo y ver
es la constante que nos da la
intersección con el eje y intersección
bien así que si nos preguntan cuál es la
pendiente de aquí bueno tendríamos que
preguntarnos cuál es el coeficiente del
término x y puedes ver que el
coeficiente del término x es este de
aquí es 6.2 y por lo tanto esa es
nuestra pendiente la pendiente es de 6.2
solo quiero que tengas mucho cuidado en
este tipo de ejercicios ojo para que
obtengas fácilmente la pendiente la yema
debe de estar despejada y debe de ser de
la forma y es igual a algo x x más algo
muy bien que te parece si entonces
hacemos otro más déjame quitar este
problema bien y ahora tenemos stem
cuál es la coordenada al origen de la
recta representada por ye igual a menos
6 x menos 11 así que una vez más estamos
en la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
y por eso está despejada nuestra y
recuerda estamos en la forma quien es
igual a m x
más ven donde recuerda m es la pendiente
que nosotros ya sabemos aquí que es
menos 6 esta es nuestra pendiente pero
no queremos la pendiente lo que queremos
es la ordenada al origen ya habíamos
dicho que era la ordenada al origen o la
intersección con el eje y en este caso
ya sabemos que valen menos 11 déjame
notarlo ve vale menos 11 ten cuidado con
los signos bueno si ve vale menos 11
observamos aquí y en ninguna de nuestras
respuestas dice que ve es igual a menos
11 entonces de qué están hablando bueno
es que la intersección james es el valor
que obtienes cuando x es igual a 0 y lo
puedes ver aquí si x es igual a 0
esta parte de aquí se cancela y me
quedarían simplemente b entonces
buscamos un punto en donde la gráfica
intersec a al eje y y ese va a ser el
punto
coma y ahora cuánto vale cuando x es
igual a cero bueno cuando x es igual a
cero llevaba a leer lo puedes ver aquí
en la ecuación original si x vale 0 esto
se va y me quedaría simplemente menos 11
entonces es el punto cero coma menos 11
y bueno en la canaca de mí tienes que
apretar la opción correcta aquí podemos
tachar la opción correcta y decir que ya
obtuvimos la solución así que de lujo
vamos a hacer uno más y para eso voy a
quitar esta pantalla y vamos a traer el
siguiente problema que es este de aquí
escribe la ecuación de una recta cuya
pendiente es 10 y se intersecta con el
eje y en el punto cero coma menos 20 así
que una vez más la forma general
es igual a m x + b
mx más ve y bueno nos dicen por aquí que
la pendiente es de 10 entonces ya
sabemos cuánto vale m me valen 10 de
lujo y por otra parte nos dicen que
interese acá con el eje y en el punto
cero coma menos 20 entonces el valor de
la vez que buscamos es el valor de james
cuando x es igual a 0 y es justo éste
que nos dan menos 20 por lo tanto
también ya sabemos que ven vale menos 20
de lujo ahora sí puedo escribir la
ecuación como james
es igual
10 que es la pendiente 10 que
multiplican a x ok más b es decir menos
20 y hemos acabado